[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه
واشنطن
النمسا جنه الجواسيس الايرانيه فينا تؤكد
ان طيران نشرت العملاء وكثفت انشطهتها
اغلبهم من الاطفال الفرنسات عيد العشرات
من عائله داعش المحتجزين في مخيمات في
سوريا
دراسه عسكريه تؤكد ان مخزونه الذخيره
الامريكيه في اي حرب محتمله مع الصين قد
تنفذ خلال اسبوع واحد
اهلا بكم
بروسيا الدائم المتحده
الغربيه
ولكن لم يتم تجاوزه جميع الخطوط الحمر بعد
بولينسكي قال في لقاء صحفي ان توليد
الاسلحه الغربيه لن يغير جذريا مساله
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه معتبرا
ان نتجاوز الخطوط الحمر يهدد بطوره الغربي
بشكل مباشر في الصراع الاوكراني كما شدد
ان الولايات المتحده
الجيش الاولاني فضلا عن ان الدول
باستخبارات الاقمار الصناعيه في موسكو
ايضا قال رئيس هيئه العامه
الروسيه الجديده تاخذ في الاعتبار التوسع
المحتمل لحلف شمال الاطلسي واخر رئيس
الاركان الجديد في اول التعليق له مهمه
بوجود مشكله في تعبئه القوات الروسيه
ده ان رئيس بوتين وافق على الاصلاحات
الجديده وان تعديلها امر وارد وفقا
للتهديدات التي تتعرض لها روسيا من حلف
الناتو وتوسعاته في فنلندا والسويد وبموجب
الخطه العسكريه الجديده سيضافوا فيلقون
عسكري الى كاريليا في شمال روسيا على
الحدود مع فنلندا الى جانب ان شاء
اللهتين في موسكو
اوكرانيا
هجمات على بلدات مجاوره بغيه تشديد الخناق
على الجيش الاوكراني والقوات الروسيه
سيطرت على مساحات واسعه من مدينه ماركا
شمال غرب الدنيا وباتت المدينه مدمرتان
بالكامل وشوارعها خاويه من السكان
الهدف من السيطره على اواخر مدينه ماهر
السيطره عليها الوصول الى اطراف مدينه
افديكا والهدف من هذا ايضا التقدم هو
الوصول الى المناطق الشماليه حيث المعارك
الاكثر سخونه حول مدينه
هنا يقاتل الجنود منذ الصباح حتى ساعه
متاخره
القصر جديد جدا وعنيف خلفنا هنا في هذه
المنطقه بالفعل نحن على الخط الاول
للمواجهه في مدينه مارينكه المتاخمه
لمدينه دانيت امل
ثم تنخفض ليلا وفيره الاشتباكات في ساعات
المساء ياخذ المقاتلون قسطا من الراحه
ويحرس الخنادق اخرون تصل الامدادات
العسكريه قبل صباح اليوم التالي وسطه هدوء
الطرفين ليتبدل الفريق باكمله وتبدا
المعارك ثانيه مع شروق الشمس يوم جديد
المواقع حيث القصف المتبادل ما بين الجنود
الروس والجنود الاوكرانيين في هذه الخطوط
الاماميه
لقناتي العربيه والحدث رائد الاخضر
دبلوماسيه التقى السفير الروسي في واشنطن
انتولي انت نوف ميناتيرته الامريكيه
الجديده التي عينه في موسكو لينا تريسي
ولم تذكري السفاره الروسيه في بيان لها
تفاصيل مدارها في هذا اللقاء الذي عقد
بمقرها في واشنطن من جهته اعلن نائب وزير
الخارجيه الروسي سيرجيريا كوف ان نستفيره
الامريكيه الجديده لدى روسيا ستصل خلال
الايام المقبله
العربيه
العسكريه الجديده التي تحدث عنها رئيس
الاركان الجديد جرسمه في روسيا
صباح الخير احمد بالفعل الجنرال جيراسيمو
الذي تحدث يوم امس ان روسيا الان مضطر الى
مواجهه الغرب باسره وذلك طبعا على خلفيه
اولا امكانيه انضمام السويد وفي اللاند
الى حلف الناتو من جانب ااا ومن جانب اخر
الزخم الكبير بالمساعده المساعدات
العسكريه التي
يوجهها الغرب واشنطن الى اوكرانيا هو قال
ان روسيا تعمل اولا من ناحيه زياده
الهيئات العسكريه كانت قد تم اعلانها من
الجانب من جانب وزير الدفاع عن السيسي
ايضا الى الهيئات العسكريه بالاضافه الى
ذلك همم عمليه التعبئه التي اتت في وقت في
وقتها المناسب كما تحدث
الغرب كما قال في اوكرانيا طبعا هو اعتبر
ان روسيا عمليات التعبئه او زياده عدد
القوات ايضا هذا ااا من الامور التي ادت
الى تحسين اداء مستوى القوات الروسيه على
ارض المعركه طبعا وزير الخارجيه اس-
الروسي سكينه مبروك كان قد قال ايضا ان
الحرب الان او العمليه العسكريه الان هناك
تحولات وليست بالحرب الهجينه ولكن هي
بالفعل حرب حقيقيه على الارض هناك مع
الغرب تحديدا همم هو قال ان روسيا طبعا هي
دائما لطالما كانت مستعده للمفاوضات ولكن
بما ان الغرب حتى الان لا يدفع اوكرانيا
الى جلوس الى طاوله مباحثات مع روسيا لذلك
روسيا ستعمل همم على كسب المزيد همم من
المناطق السيطره على الكثير من المناطق في
اوكرانيا اريد تكون طرف همم قوي في مع بعض
اذا جلست الى طاوله المحادثات فقط
اوكرانيا احمد طيب هو ايضا
رئيس الاركان الروسي موف تحدث عن مشاكل
توجهها البلاد في التعبئه العسكريه وهو لم
يوضح طبيعه هذه المشاكل لكن هل هناك
معلومات حول ذلك وهل يشمل ذلك ايضا ضعفا
الاق من الشعب الروسي او من الراي العام
الروسيه اتجاه هذه التعبئه
يعني كان وزير الدفاع الروسي والرئيس
الروسي كان قد اعلن انتهاء العمليات او
عمليه التعبئه الجزئيه التي اتم اعلانها
في العام القادم السابق القوات الروسيه
تتلقى التدريبات التي تم تعبئتها تتلقى
التدريبات الان منها من توجه الى خط
المواجهه ومنها من لا يزال يتدرب على حمل
السلاح في مراكز التدريب الخاصه لاربما
طبعا الاضافه الى القوات الروسيه هناك
القوات المتطوعين ايضا التي تطوعت نفسها
لذهاب الى القتال والمتعاقدين ايضا او
هناك مشاكل ربما هي مشاكل تقنيه لربما هي
في وصول السلاح والمتاح الى القوات
الرومانسيه هذه من المشاكل التي تم حلها
كما حدثتها في وقت السابقه ايضا وزير
الدفاع الروسيه
حينما قال ان هناك مشكله في تعبئه القوات
الروسيه شكرا لك على التوضيح تحياتي لك من
بوصل معنا ورثه العربيه كانت يطعمه
مشاهدينا تلعبوا الخنادق دورا محورين لدى
القوات الاوكرانيه في الجبهات الاماميه
القتال حيث شيد الجنود اوكران مجموعه بتلك
الخنادق بالمقابل قائمه القوات الروسيه
ايضا بحفل الفنادق والتعازيز دفاعاتها في
المناطق الواقعه تحت سيطرتها
هنا ليس هذا هو السلاح فقط سلاح الاخر امر
الخنادق من خرسون وبخمود الى سوليدار الى
ميكو لايف تنتشر هذه الخنادق بالاضافه الى
خنادق اخرى تم تشيدها على طول حدود
اوكرانيا مع بلاروسيا لتشكل جميعها خط
الدفاع الاول للجنود الاوكرانيين في
مواجهه روسيا يعيش المجندون الشتاء في
الخنادق مثل جميع الجنود منذ قرون النظم
تشكل تلك المواقع ما صدقت الدفاعيه مصممه
للوقوف في وجه اي هجوم كما تعطل الخنادق
والتحصنات اي تول محتمل في تلك المنطقه
لكن الارضيه الصلبه التي يفضلها بنات هذه
الخنادق قد تجعل من السهل على العدو
التقدم وقد يشكل موقعهم احيانا هدفا سهلا
ان تم استهدافه من على القمم العاليه تست
وتلك الخنادق جنود العدو مسلحين بالقنابل
اليدويه والبنادق الرشاشه ويحاولون
الاقتراب قدر المستطاع لمجرد القاء
القنابل اليدويه على الخنادق في معظم
الاحيان يموت الجنود في كتل من الطين
الملوثه على حدود هذه الخنادق
بين الحياه والموت تقف ارواح الجنود بين
جدارين تحت الارض بين الصقيع ونيران
المدافع متسلحين بخنادقهم في المنطقه
المحرمه
الخناقه
عصام عبد السلام العربيه
اوضحت الفاين اشياء تايمز انا الدبابات
الغربيه ستمنح اوكرانيا ميزه على الدبابات
الروسيه لانها تمتلك دروعا متفوقه ومدافع
اكثر دقه وانظمه التحكم من وملاحه افضل ما
يتيح القيام بعمليات ليليه
الدبابات الثقيله راس الحربه في اي هجوم
او دفاع توفر مستوى عاليا جدا من الحمايه
ضد اسلحه النيران المباشره
تساعد في التحرك بسرعه على الطرق
والتضاريس الوعره تعمل على الاتجاهات
الحاسمه وخرق المناطق المحصنه والنفادي
عمق العدو
تعد القوه الضاربه الاهم في القوه
العسكريه لاي الجيش
وشاطر دفاعات العدو وتدميرها
تمتلك قوه اختراق اكبر
وتوفر القوه الناريه والقدره على المناوره
مع الامين العام لحلفي شمال الاطلس في
المانيا لمواصله بحث قضيه توريد الدبابات
الى اوكرانيا
بشان تسليم اسلحه ثقيله الى كيف كما دعاه
وزاره الخارجيه ليتوانيا
دعوا المانيا الى سرعه تقديم دبابات
اليوبار الى اوكرانيا لمواجهه القوات
الروسيه وتاتي دعوته وزراء خارجيه دول
البلطيق بعد اعلان وزير الدفاع الالماني
عدم امكانيه التوصل الى اتفاق بشان سماح
برلين
لكنه اوضح في الوقت ذاته ان برلين ستواصل
دراسته هذه المساله
مشاهدينا الى هذا الخبر العاجل نقلا عن
وكاله رويترز قاضي التحقيق بانفجار مرفاي
بيروت يحدد جلسات الاستجواب المدعي العام
والقضاء المتهمين وقبل ايضا خبر عاجلا قد
التحقيق
بيوجه تهم للمدعي العام وثلاثه قضاه اخرين
وسنوافيكم بمزيد من التفاصيل حاله وورده
حول هذا الملف
افاد مراسل العربيه بان مدير الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه رافائيل جروسي
سيجتمع مع النوابي اعضاء لجنه الشؤون
الخارجيه في البرلماني الاوروبي وذلك
لمناقشه سلامه المنشات النوويه في
اوكرانيا في سياق متصل قالت وزيره الطاقه
الامريكيه جنيفر ان مشروع الميزانيه
الامريكيه للسنه الماليه 2023 ينص على
تخصيص اكثر من 226 مليون دولار في حاله
وقوع حادث النووي على الاراضي اوكرانيا
حيث سيتم تخصيص المبلغ لدعم برنامج عدم
الانتشار النووي للاستجابه للوضعي في
اوكرانيا
مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل وسط
التزايد التوتر بشان برنامج ايران النووي
القياده المركزيه الامريكيه تعلن عن تدريب
المشترك مع اسرائيل في شرق المتوسط
[موسيقى]
ميرسي هذه الاوقات على شاشه العربيه
تستمر في تسجيل مستويات متدنيه اسواق اسيا
تسجل تراجعات في ظل بالطبع خوف المستثمرين
فيما يخص بتداعيات الحرب الاكرانيه
الروسيه هناك استراتيجيه وتحول كبير خاصه
مثلا من دول المانيا لزياده الانترنت
والغاز الروسي الى الولايات المتحده
الهولندي
مقاطعه سريعه لهذا القطاع الروسي ممكن ان
يسبب باسماء اقتصاديه عالميه موريس جونسون
قال على اوروبا ان تقدم على هذا الموضوع
خطوه خطوه نتجه لتطورات الحرب الروسيه
الالكترونيه سجلت عده معادن افهم قياسيه
صباح اليوم وارتفع سعر برميل
للعام 2008
تبقى بدون تغيير البيت الابيض يشعر بالرضا
بانه من خلال هذه العقوبات الجماعيه سيكون
هناك تاثير موجع للاقتصاد الروسي وكمال
رئيس كوريا
معكم بالتغطيه من الجوانب الماليه
والاقتصاديه للاحداث في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد في وقت يتزايد
فيه التوتر بشان برنامج ايران النووي
اعلان ترقيات المركزيه الامريكيه عن بدء
تدريب المشترك مع الجيش الاسرائيلي في شرق
البحر المتوسط وقالت القياده في بيان ان
تدريب يمتد لاسرائيل ايضا ويعزز استعداد
القوات الى جانب التزام واشنطن تجاه منطقه
الشرق الاوسط وذكر البيان ان التدريب
يشارك فيه اكثر من 140 طائره بينها 52 10
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن ترميم
موسكو ودمشق لقاعده الجراح الجويه
العسكريه شمال سوريا وذلك استخدامها بشكل
مشترك وقالت الوزاره في بيان ان ترميم
المطار العسكري الذي دمر اثناء اعمال
عدائيه سيعجل بل سيجعل تغطيه حدود الدوله
السوريه وتامينها امرا ممكنا
قال المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني ان بلاده ستعلن عن
قائمه جديده من العقوبات ضد منتهي في حقوق
الانسان في الاتحاد الاوروبي وبريطانيا
الرئاسه السويديه الى الاتحاد الاوروبي ان
وزراء التكتل اقر وحزمه جديده من العقوبات
على ايران بسبب اقامه
انها سترد عليها قبل ذلك حضر الاتحاد
الاوروبي السلطات الايرانيه على وقف
الحمله العنيف على الاحتياجات السلميه
والافراج عن جميع المعتقلين بشكل غير
قانوني وهكذا الاتحاد الاوروبي مواصله
دعوته لنظام الايراني للتوقع
وتنفي احكام الاعدام ضد المتظاهرين
النمسا مشاهدينا جنه الجواسيس هكذا علقت
هيئه الاذاعه النمساويه في مقايي الله على
تقرير للمخابرات النمساويه يفيد بان
عمليات التجسس السيبراني في البلاد
تنفيذها الى حد كبير ايران وروسيا والصين
كما كشفت تغيير ان النظام الايرانيه ينشر
انشطته للتجسس في النمسا على مدى سنوات
حيث تعد جذابه له بسبب العقوبه الجنائيه
الضعيفه على مثل هذه الجرائم كما اشارت
تقيل الذي نشرته صحيفه
الايرانيه نشرت شبكه من الجواسيس في
النمسا على مر السنين حيث يلعبوا فيلقوا
القدس تابع للحرس الثوري الايراني دورا لا
يستهان به وقالت الصحيفه انسى تعد ايضا
بؤره لنشاط التجسس بسبب وضعها الجغرافي
السياسي الجيد فضلا عن انها موقع لعدد من
المنظمات الدوليه اضافه الى قوتها
الاقتصاديه تقرير المخابرات النمساويه
اشار ايضا الى ان عمليات التجسس تتم تحت
غطاء الدبلوماسيه في السفارات والقنصليات
الاجنبيه كما اكد ايضا المخابرات النمساوي
ان الجواسيس الاجانب يعملون ايضا في
النوادي والمراكز الثقافيه والوكالات
الانباء وشركات الطيران او مواقع الاعمال
الاخرى
افاد الشركه بالشبكه كردستان لحقوق
الانسان بان الشابه كوثر خشنودي كيا وصيفه
بطوله الرمايه الاسيويه رغم اجراء عمليه
جراحيه لعينها اليسرى الا انها فقدتها
بسبب اصابتها برصاص خلال احتجاجات مدينه
كرماشاه غربيه ايران في التاسع من ديسمبر
الماضي
مشاهدينا ينضم الينا من الرياضه الباحث في
شان الايراني صالح حميد احمد اهلا بك سيد
صالح معنا في هذه الاشرار كما تابعنا اذا
النمسا باتت جنه الجواسيس المخابرات
النمساويه كما تبان ايضا في التقدير او في
الخبر الماضي همم عدده الاسباب التي جعلت
من هذه البلاد جنه لجواسيس لكن من الناحيه
او من الجانب الايراني الجانب النظام
الايراني ما الذي يريده من بلد لمسه
[موسيقى]
عبيد من الافراد والعملاء منتشرون في همم
القاره الاوروبيه خاصه دول اوروبا الغربيه
همم لا ننسى الله اسئله الذي كان يعمل
دبلوماسيه في السفاره الايرانيه في النمسا
هو الذي همم كان العقل المدبر وراء محاوله
تفجير مؤتمر معرض الايرانيه في فرنسا عام
2018 والذي سلم على بلجيكا مع افراد قريته
وحكمه هناك ب 20 عاما من خلال تطبيقات وجد
دفتر بحوزه همم
اسدي يحتوي على قوائم
للعملاء والجواسيس الذين يعملون بشكل
مباشر لصالح اجهزه المخابرات الايرانيه في
11 دوله اوروبيه وكان اسدي قد جعل من همم
مكتب مكتبه السفاره
رانيا في فينا النمسا كما حط لي المخابرات
الايرانيه لذلك ااا النظام يستغل سياسه
المهادنه والترابه التي انتهجتها اوروبا
على مدى العديد همم من العقود الماضيه
ولذلك همم تمادى النظام الايراني في هذه
الانشطه سواء
لاستهداف المعارضين بشكل مباشر من خلال
الاغتيالات والتفجيرات
جواسيس او هذه الخلايا النائمه لا يقتصر
فقط على جمع المعلومات والى ما حتى القيام
بعمليات تخريبيه حال ما راى النظام ان
الوقت المناسب قد جاء الان
صحيح يعني نشاطهم
منقسم الى جمع المعلومات
ايضا عمليات اغتيال عمليات تفجير العديد
من هؤلاء تم القبض عليهم سواء في النمسا
في السويد في بلجيكا فرنسا المانيا
والاخرى
الانشطه الاخرى التي يقوم بها هؤلاء
العديد منهم متنفسجون في مراكز الابحاث
والدراسات والان بعود سوره النظام
الايراني وبالمناسبه العديد منهم من ابناء
مسؤولين النظام كانت الدول اوروبيه تتغاظك
سنوات الماضيه عن هؤلاء الاشخاص نظرا
للعلاقات التجاريه والاقتصاديه خاصه بعد
انتفاخ النووي عام 2015 لكن مع تدهور هذه
العلاقات خلال سنوات الماضيه وخاصه خلال
الاشهر الاخيره بسبب الاحتجاج داخل ايران
وموجه الاعدامات وايضا من جهه اخرى توقف
الاتفاق والمفاوضات بدات بعض هذه الدول
بكشف هذه الملفات والاعلان عن هذه الخلايا
تمهيدا لمحاسبتها والكثير من بالطب مع
انتشار هذه الاخبار عادوا الى ايران لكن
الكثير منهم بالتاكيد
الايراني
يعتقدت ثلاثه صحفيات على خلفيه انشطه
متعلقه بالتغطيه الاعلاميه منذ بدايه
الاحتياجات في منتصف سبتمبر الماضي وقالت
المنظمه في بيان ان عدد الصحفيين الذين
القت السلطه الايرانيه القبض عليهم
ارتفع الى 55 من بينهم 16 صحفيه واضاف
البيان ان السلطات لا تزال 27 من الصحفيين
بينما اخذت سبيل الاخرين بكفاله في انتظار
محاكمتهم وداعت المنظم السلطات الايرانيه
هي الافراج الفوريه عن الصحفي المعتقلين
واسقاط جميع التهم الموجهه اليهم
هذا هو اعلى الاتحاد الاوروبي عن حزمه
عقوبات الرابعه ضد ايران تستهدف عارضا من
جنرالات لحرس الثوري وكياناته في المقابل
ابقى وزراء الخارجي المشهوره مفتوحه اذا
مساله ادراج الحرس الثوري في قائمه
الارهاب الاوروبيه نحن نتابع حزمه
العقوبات الاوروبيه الرابعه ضد ايران تعكس
تصميم دول الاتحاد على تجديد الضغط على
ايران من اجل ان تخفف القبضه على
المتظاهرين
الحزمه الجديده تشمل ثمانيه عشر مسؤولا
منهم خمسه درجات الحارس الثوري و 19 كيانا
منها اثنا عشر كيا تابعا لجهاز
الحاسيلوا دعم الايرانيين في الدفاع عن
حقوقهم الاساسيه هذا الموقف وابلغتهم
مرارا الى وزير الخارجيه الايراني وقد
صدقنا اليوم على حزمه العقوبات الرابعه
بموجب نظام انتهاكات حقوق الانسان في
ايران
قانونيه واخرى دبلوماسيه
الايراني في قائمه الارهاب
القانون الاوروبي يقتضي اولا وقبل كل شيء
توفر حكم القضاء في احد الدول الاوروبيه
منذ عام 2010 في قائمه العقوبات المتصله
بالانتشار نووي واسلحه الدمار الشامل
وقوائم اخرى
اليوم نبحث في امكانيه ادراجه بموجب نظام
اخر ننظر في الامر عن قرب ولا نستبعد اي
خيار
فرنسا دعيت شركاها الى التفكيري معا في
الرد المناسب على سياسه الرهائن التي
تسلكها ايران حيث تحتجز العشرات من
الاوروبيين ومتزوجيه الجنسيه بعضهم حكم
عليهم
عاما مثل ما حدث للبلجيكي اوليفيا
المباحثات الاوروبيه لا تستثني ايا من
ابعاد العلاقات المتوفره
العلاقات
وتنفيذ عقوبه الاعدام وتزويدها روسيا
بالسلاح مشكله مزدوجيه الجنسيه والرعايه
الاوروبيين المحتجزين في ايران تم بحثت
هذه القضايا كافه طبيعتها المعقده لا
تيسير التقدم في مفاوضات الاتفاق النووي
الجامده في الضرب وضع العلاقات الاوروبيه
الايرانيه معقده للغايه بسبب قمع
المظاهرات السلميه ودعم ايران لروسيا
عسكريا ودورها المزعزع للاستقرار في
المنطقه الى جانب جمود الاتفاق النووي
ودبلوماسيه الرهاني الاتحاد الاوروبي يفضل
ادراج المسؤولين في الحرس الثوري الايراني
وكياناته في قوائم العقوبه تدريجيا
منهجيه تمكن الاتحاد من الابقاء على قناه
التواصل مع ايران مفتوحه قناه ضروريه اذا
توفرت الرغبه لاحياء الاتفاق النووي
نور الدين الفريق العربي
والى متابعه التحقيقات القضائيه مع قيادات
حركه النهضه في تونس ينتظر اليوم ان يمثل
رئيس الحكومه الاسبق حمادي الاجباري امام
القضاء لسماعه في قضيه منح جوازات السفر
على علاقه بحركه النهضه كما وجهت نيابه
طلب الى البنوك بتجميد حسابات البنكيه
الماليه تابعه لاكثر من 100 شخص وشركه
ومادها بقيمه الاسد المجمده وذلك في اطار
طورطهم في قضايا غسل اموال
هذا هو عقيد المجلس الاعلى المؤقت القضاء
في تونس جلسه للنظر في مطالب نحو عشره
قضام بينهم بل من بين المعفيين من عملهم
بموجب بقرار من القطب القضائيين مكافحه
الارهاب وذكرت هيئه الدفاع عن القضاه
المعفيين في تونس انها قدمت سبع 37 شكوى
جزائيه ضد وزيره العدل الى جفال وذلك بسبب
عدم اعادتهم وظائفهم رغم قرار المحكمه
الاداريه بايقاف تنفيذ الاعفاء وكان رئيس
قيس سعيد عدل سبعه وخمسين قاضيا في يونيو
الماضي بعد اتهامه بالفساد والتستر على
متهمين في قضايا ارهاب لكن المحكمه
الاداريه قضت في العاشر من اغسطس بايقافه
تنفيذ اعفاء 50 قاضيا منهم
مستمرا مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل مسؤول
اماميه سعاليق مع طالبان بالغاء الحظر على
عمل النساء
تتمتع دول الخليج بقيمه عالميه كبيره
لليوم رخاء وتطور وضعها على خريطه الدول
الاولى
لكن المنطقه التي نعيش فيها مليئه
بالسلاحات تهديدات اقليميه من دول اخرى
منظمات ارهابيه وجماعات المسلحه كيف يمكن
ما هي التحديات التي تواجهها الدول وهذه
المجتمعات هل يمكن المضيء قدوما في مساء
التنميه دون تفتيك الالغام الثقافيه
وبنائي ذهنيه الحاضنه للتنميه في كل
مجالات اهم الموضوعات المتعلقه بالشكل
الخليجي مع ابرز المحللين والمختصرين
هذا البرنامج يحاول صحبه سله من المعنيين
ارتياده هذا الطريق الصعب ان توافق مع
مشاري الزايدي السبت الثالثه والنصف على
شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
والعالميه
حول العالم
[موسيقى]
تقاريرو ميادين اللعب ومتابعه وتحليل
[تصفيق]
لكل الرياضه في هذه الاوقات
من تجاوز الخطوط الحمر في اوكرانيا وسفير
موسكو يلتقي نظيره الامريكي بوشنطن
النمسا جنه الجواسيس الايرانيه فيانا تؤكد
ان طهر ان نشرت العملاء وكثفت انشطتها
اغلبهم يا الاطفال فرنسا تعيد العشرات من
عائلات داعش المحتجزين في مخيمات في سوريا
دراسه عسكريه تؤكد ان مخزونات الذخيره
الامريكيه في اي حرب محتمله مع الصين قد
تنفذ خلال اسبوع واحد
مره اخرى الى سياق الاخبار
يعني طبعا حسب بعض المعلومات قاد التحفيظ
طارق قد التحقيق طارق البيطار همم كان قد
اعلن عن ربما هناك ازدهار وقد ارسل هذه
الدعاءات للوصول الاسبوع المقبل بينها
اثناء قضاه من الدرجه الاولى ابرزهم مدعي
عام التمييز غسان عويدات ااه وهو من اعلى
المراكز القضائيه في لبنان المعلومات تشير
والمصادر تشير الى انه كان هناك يعني كان
لديه السلطه باصدار قرار لاخراج الامونيوم
من المراه ولكن لم يتخذ هذا القرار ايضا
بعد المصادر المطلعه اشارت الى ان همم
الجديده التي صدرت بثمانيه اسماء جديده
بينها امين لواء عبد الباسط
يبدوا ان هذه الرائحه لن تكون الاخيره
وهناك اسماء اخرى ستكون اشد واقع من
الاسماء التي صدرت هذه المره ايضا نذكر
فقط انه اا كان هناك اجتهاد ودراسه
قانونيه من قبل القاضي طارق البيطار الذي
توقف او كفته يده عن العمل لمده عام وشهر
لكن قانونيه قام بها همم عاد الى العمل
اتخذ قرار شخصي بعودته الى العمل وقاضي
تحقيق اليوم لانه معين من مجلس الوزراء
كما ذكر في دراستها القانونيه هو لديه
منصب همم
يعني اعلى من المنصب العام التمييز ويحق
له استدعائهم في حال كان هناك همم بعض
المعلومات
يعني اا يعني بعض المعلومات اشارت الى انه
يمكن ان تكون هذه الجلسات الاسبوع المقبل
ولكن بطبيعه الحال ليس اا يعني ليس من
المتوقع ان يحضر من تم استدعائهم كان كما
جرى في المرات السابقه ولكن مجرد عوده
عوده طارق البيطار رغم كل الضغوطات
السياسيه والمواجهات السياسيه يعني ان هذا
الملف اليوم هو على نار حاميه وهناك ايضا
تخوفات امنيه همم
هذه همم يعني هذه التطورات نعم نعم
من قبل الاهالي الضحايا الان هذه تنميه
المطالب الرئيسيه طبعا في الفتره الماضيه
يعني بالطبع طبعا اهالي الضحايا اعتبروا
ان قرار القاضي البيطار اعاده الروح الى
التحقيق المتوسطه وهذا كان طلبهم الاساسي
خاصه وانهم في الاسبوع الماضي تم توقيف
لاحد الضحايا بدلا من ان يكون
وزراء صادقين وايضا كان هناك
اذا كان الطلبه
في خلال العام الماضي باستدعاء اللواء
عباس ابراهيم ولم يحث على هذا الاذن ليتخذ
اليوم هذا القارئ القرار
كم حقق عليه
هذا الملف شكرا
اعاده فرنسا 15 امراه واثنين وثلاثين طفلا
كانوا معتقلين في مخيمات يحتجز فيها عناصر
متطرفه شمال شرق سوريا علامه وزاره
الخارجيه فرنسا
الى الاجهزه المكلفه بمساعده الاطفال
وستقدم لهم متابعه طبيه اجتماعيه مضيفه ان
البالغات سلمنا الى السلطات القضائيه
المختصه
مشاهدينا حول هذا الموضوع من باريس انضم
الينا مراسل العربيه حسين يقنيب اهلا بك
يا حسين هل وصل جميع الرعايه الفرنسيين في
داعش الى باريس وما الذي انتظره هناك حسين
ايضا
نعم احمد في الواقع السلطات الفرنسيه لا
تشير الى موعد وصول هؤلاء وانما تتحدث عن
عودتهم من سوريا الاطفال من بينهم القصر
سيسلمون الى الاجهزه التي تتابع حالات من
هذا النوع
وستضمن هذه الاجهزه المتابعه الطبيه
والاجتماعيه لهؤلاء اما الكبار فاس يسلمون
سيسلمون تحديدا لانهم من النساء في معظمهم
هؤلاء النساء يسلمن الى الجهات القضائيه
المختصه كانت لجنه مناهضه التعذيب في
الامم المتحده اتهمت فرنسا بمخالفه معاهده
منظمه معاهده التعذيب التي تلزم كل الدول
الموقعه على المعاهده بحمايه الذين
يتعرضون للتعذيب ردت فرنسا على ذلك بالقول
ان هذه المعاهده خصوصا في بنديها الثاني
والسادس عشر لا تلزم اي بلد على استيعاده
مواطنه بل على حمايه مواطنيه في بلد لا
يقع تحت سلطته القضائيه ثم ان الامر لا
يعود لفرنسا وحدها لضمان حمايه هؤلاء
واستعادتهم خاضعه لاتفاقات مع الجهه
المسيطره على البلد الذي يتواجد الحسين
ومؤتمر صحفي لوزير الدفاع الالمانيه
الجديده
هوتم فؤاد
قال المتحدث باسم الاويم المتحده ستيفن دو
جارك ان منسق الشؤون الانسانيه والاغاثه
في الامم المتحده مارتن جريفد سيجاره
العاصمه الافغانيه كابول مع رئيستين
منظمتين اغافيتين دوريتين كبيرتين لاقناع
اطالبان بالغاء الحضري على عمل النساء
واضافت ذلك ان حضره طالبان عمل افغانيات
في المنظمات غير الحكوميه شهر الماضي اوقف
بعض برامج المساعده واثار مخاوف من تفاقم
طرد الوضع الانساني في افغانستان كما ذكر
ان نحو ثمانيه 20 مليون افغاني بعده بحاجه
الى زياده امدادات الغذاء والدواء
ومساعدات انسانيه اخرى
احاول الحصول على قراءه بسيطه لجدولهم
الزمني على الارض
لكن من الواضح انهم سيتعاملون مع الامر
الواقع من منطلق الرساله التي قدمناها منذ
البدايه بشان الحاجه الى التراجع عن
السياسات التي تم وضعها الى جانب التاكيد
على ان المساعدات الانسانيه لا يمكن
تسليمها بدون النساء ليس من الاخلاق
القيام بذلك بدونه وليس من المجدي عمليا
القيام بذلك بدون مشاركه المراه النشطه
عشرات الاطفال من طالب اللجوء غير
المصحبين بدويهم في بريطانيا في ظروف
غامضه وصفها مبلغ عنها بالاختطاف من قبل
عصابات الاجراميه وفق ما جاء في تقرير
انني 136 طفله مفقودا في الاشهر الثمانيه
عشر الماضي 10 الماضيه لا يزال 79 منهم في
عداد المفقودين وتطالب المجموعه العماليه
في في بلديه برايتون ان هوفت باجراء تحقيق
عاجل في الاطفال المفقودين
فاو عشرات الاطفال من طالب اللجوء كانوا
يقيمون في هذا الفندق الذي تديره وزاره
الداخليه يثير صدمه كبيره في الاوساط
السياسيه والحقوقيه في بريطانيا مع كشف
تحقيق ان ما يقارب من 80 طفلا لا يزالون
في عداد المفقودين
واقعه تقشعر لها الابدان بالرامي من
التحذيرات المتكرره لوزاره الداخليه بان
الاطفال اللاجئين غير مسحوبين بدويهم
مستهدفون من قبل الشبكات الاجراميه وربما
يتم الاتجار ببعضهم بعيدا عن الفندق الذي
ياويههم
وكانه مشهد من فيلم لا تتوقع ان يحدث في
اي مكان في مكان معين هنا في المملكه
المتحده
جيده وتحديد مكانهم ومعرفه سبب اختفائهم
حالات اختفاء اطفال اللاجئين التي وصفها
احد الموظفين مع شركه لحمايه الاطفال
متعاقده مع وزاره الداخليه سجلت ايضا في
فنادق اخرى ما دفع القياده العماليه في
مجلس برايتون الى المطالبه باجراء تحقيق
عاجل في الاطفال المفقودين
الاطفال في امان وحصلنا على ضمانات بان كل
شيء على ما يرام ومن ثم بدانا نسمع
باشاعات ان الامور ليست كذلك
وكشفت بيانات رسميه قبل اربعه اشهر انني
222 من طالب اللجوء فقدوا من فنادقات تشرف
عليها وزاره الداخليه وحينها اعترف
الوزراء بانه ليست لديهم فكره عن مكان
وجودهم
المعارضه انتقدت وزاره الداخليه لاخفاقها
في حمايه سلامه الاطفال او قمع العصابات
الاجراميه التي تعرضهم للخطر وطلبه بوضع
ترتيبات جديده لحمايتهم على وجه السرعه
والكشف عن عدد المفقودين والاجراءات التي
تم اتخاذها للعثور عليهم من مدينه
بريطانيا العربيه
ذكر البيت الابيض ان وزاره العدل فتشت
منزل الرئيس الجمعه هو ذلك بعد عرض توعين
وسباقه قدمه محامي الشخصيه الوزاره
محامي رئيس ان بعض الوثائق السريه ترجع
الى فتره
كانت في فتره منصبه نائب الرئيس في اداره
الرئيس اوباما من 2009 حتى 2017
حضرت منظمه الاجراءات التي فرضتها اسرائيل
مؤخرا على دخول الاجانب الى الضفه الغربيه
لانه لا شان الجيش الاحتلال بتحديد
المدرسين في الجامعات الفلسطينيه او بمنع
الحقوقيين من التفاعل مع السكان المحتلين
او تشتيت العائلات بقسوه وفقولها
من جهتها اعتبر اسرائيل ان الاجراءات تهدف
الى توضيح اليات دخول الضفه الغربيه وقبلت
الاجراءات الاخيره باذنه من قبل الاتحاد
الاوروبي مباشره
كشفت مصادر كرديه
قطعت نحو نصف مياه نهر الفرات عن سوريا
مع فقدان الامل في قدره امطار الشتاء على
تعويض هذا النقص
الفرات العظيم قد لا يدوم عظيما تركيا
قطعت نصفه
بامره سنوات
قبل ان تتراجع كل هذه المسافتي الى ادنى
مستوى في تاريخ النهر
لتنكمش الى هنا وذلك بسبب تقلص الوارد
المائي الى مئتين 250 متر مكعب في الثانيه
من اصل 500 متر مكعب متفق عليه مع تركيا
الواقع الجديد هبط بانتاج الكهرباء من
السدود الرئيسيه ودفع الاداره المحليه الى
زياده التقنيين الذي شمل ايضا مياه الري
والشرب كما فاقم المشاكل الصحيه جراء تلوث
مياه النهر
والله هذا جاني استر علينا لانه حتى عندنا
مشاريع تطلع مياه زراعيه مثلا صارت تنقص
عنها صارت تغنون بالنسبه لقطع الماء حبسه
من تركيا هذا غلط لازم كل العالم اتدخل مو
بسوريا عم تشرب منها المي عم تروح على
العراق عم تروح على كل الدنيا نطلب من
الله انه هل القادات المسؤولين الدول
العربيه مثل الخليج مثل هالدول هاي توقف
معانا يعني
المسؤولون الاكراد راها انو هذا الشتاء
على الامطار لتخزين كميات اكبر من المياه
في السدود الا ان غيابها شكل صدمه للجميع
مع سليمان قطع المياه من طرف تركيا واسمر
الموسم الشتوي الجاف التخوف ان يكون هناك
ربيع جاف علينا والصيف اييي يعني مخيف على
مجمل انتاج سدود من مياه الشرب او قنوات
الري او الطاقه الكهربائيه
[موسيقى]
ونغم المخاطر التي تهدد حياه مليون انسان
في سوريا فقط لا تزال مشكله نهر غائبه عن
طاوله الحوار بين تركيا سوريا والعراق كما
يبدو ان الاطراف الدوليه غير مهتمه ببساطه
تحول دون وقوع الكارثه من الرقه العربيه
ولا مشاهدينا الى وقفه مع نادينا
اهلا بكم
بجوله على تداولات اسواق المنطقه اليوم
الصوره الخضراء
في الاسواق العالميه والارتفاعات على
النفط ايضا النفط متماسك عند 88 دولار على
مزيد اعلى مستويات بسبعه اسابيع وذلك في
ظل قصه اعاده فتح الاقتصاد الصيني وما
يعنيه من ارتفاع للطلب على طلب على نصب
الفتره القادمه ولو ان الصين حاليا مغلقه
بعطله راس السنه القمريه بدل من الحادي
والعشرين من يناير هذه اسعار النفط برنس
88 دولار و30 سنه
82$ فاذا هذه الاسباب الرئيسيه وراء
ارتفاعات الاسواق بالاضافه الى توجهها
لاخذ المخاطر نرى بالاسواق العالميه بدا
من الارتفاعات الاسواق الامريكيه يوم امس
السوق السعودي على ارتفاع بربع نقطه مئويه
الان دبي وابو ظبي ارتفاعات بحدود الثلث
النقطه المئويه خلينا نبدا من السعوديه
حيث السعودي للاستثمار على تراجع المتابعه
هذا السهم اليوم في ظل خبر بانه لديه ثقوب
داخله بالشرق الاول من راس المال هذه سقوط
برفات شو بدون استحقاق ولكنها قوله من بعد
خمس كم تم اصدار هذه الصكوك بمارس 2018
لان بيمارس من هذا العام هي كولا بالبنك
راح يسترده وبالتالي راح يعمل سداد على
هذه الفقوق ومقابل ذلك لديه برنامج قائم
للسقوق سيرفع حجمه من مليارين لخمسه
مليارات ريال ويقوم بتصويق شريحه من
الصكوك يستبدل بها تلك التي يسددها خلنا
ننقدر على الاسهم القياديه بالسعوديه
بالوقت الحاضر قبل ان نذهب الى اسواق اخرى
بالقطاع المصري في الرياضه على تراجع صعب
الاهلي الفرنسي الراجحي على ارتفاع المواد
الاساسيه السابق على ارتفاع والتصنيع
بينما معادن ولبراف على تراجع ونظره على
قطاع الاتصالات على تباين عذيب على ارتفاع
باقي الاسهم على نزول سنكتفي بهذا القدر
بهذه الفقره عضو القاكم برنامج الاسواق
العربيه بعد قليل عوده اليك احمد الان
شكرا ناديه وانا اول مره اخرى مشاهدينا
الى برلين المؤتمر الصحفي لوزير الدفاع
الالماني والامين العام الحلف الناتو
انظمه اخرى مثل الايراني
يجب ان يكون واضح
انه لا يستطيع الانتصار في ساحه المعركه
لذلك السلام لابد من مسار اخر له وبالتالي
القوه الالكترونيه
للمدارس والمناطق المدنيه
بهجمه صاروخيه على يد
القوات الروسيه واعلنت
الولايات المتحده في رانشتاين يوم الجمعه
همم عن 2.5 مليار همم دولار امريكي من
الدعم
لاسلحه
والدفاعات الجويه
وهمم اسلحه متقدمه وفرنسا وبريطانيا وكل
الحلفاء الاخرين اعلنوا انهم سيخسوا
يقدمون للاكران
ادب الدبابات وفي هذه المرحله الحاسمه من
الحرب لا بد ان نقدم اسلحه متطوره وكذلك
همم
دخيل عليه الافكار وقد نقشنا
قنصل تعيش
والمشاورات تستمر وسنخرج بحلول قريبا
المانيا
لها دور اساسي في هذا
التحالفن
ب 600 مليار من الدفاعات الجويه
والطائرات العموديه والسفن والدبابات
النيته
الباديه مستعده لان تكون في قوات التدخل
السريعه للاتحاد الاوروبي وهذا لتعزيز
قوانه ودفاعات المختلفه اشكركم على هذا
الاجتماع الرائع ونتطلع لنقاشات
وارحب سنلتقي بكم ايضا في بروكسل في
الاجتماع وزراء دفاع في الشهر المقبل
رساله دفاعات الجويه لمساعده اوكرانيه
المانيا اليوم
مره اخرى مشاهدينا في مصر
قال كافه تكاليف الانتاج ووسط مطالبات
بمساوات السعر شراء القمح المحلي بسعر
القمح المستورد
ينسون انهم يحصلون على كثير من المنتجات
الاخرى
محي مصطفى سيزرع قمح هذا العام ليكرر
تجربه العام الماضي نظرا لانه يعرف مسبقا
السعر الذي سيبيع به فقد رفعت الحكومه سعر
شراء القمح المحلي في محاوله لتجنب الوقوع
في ازمه توريد للقمح بسبب التطورات
العالميه ورغم رفع السعر الا ان شكاوى
المزارعين لم تتوقف عاليه جدا
من خمس شكاير لوليا يعني كنت حضرتك احب زي
ما بيجيبوا من بره ياخدوا مني حضرتك
مثل محصول القمح من الزراعه حتى حصل عندما
هو حطك يعني حتى لو تلاحظ انه في مزارع
على مستوى جمهوريه كان العالم السابق بس
اشهر دم للفدان انما الحقول الارشاديه
انموذجيه كالمتصطادها على مستوى جمهوريه
كان 25 ارض الفدان بدات زراعه القمح في
نوفمبر الماضي في مصر واقبل عليها
المزارعون بعد ما حسبوا حساباتهم كالمعتاد
فوجدوها مناسبه عند السعر المعلن وقتها
واليوم وبعد تحرير سعر الصرف جاءت الزياده
في سعر التوريد للصوامع الحكوميه كحافزا
اضافيه
بحشرات اللي موجوده فيها تامر العربيه
محافظه القليوبيه
العناوين مشاهدينا
روسيا تحذر الغربه من تجاوز الخطوط الحمر
في اوكرانيا وسفير موسكو يلتقي نظيره
الامريكي بي واشنطن
النمسا جنه الجواسيس الايرانيه فينا تؤكد
ان طهر ان نشرت العملاء وكثفت انشطتها
اغلبهم يا الاطفال فرنسا تعيد العشرات من
عائلات داعش المحتجزين في مخيمات في سوريا
دراسه عسكريه تؤكد ان مخزونات الذخيره
الامريكيه في اي حرب محتمله مع الصين قد
تنفذ خلال اسبوع واحد
نهايه وادي سعد